et à la une de l'actualité
internationale ce matin également
djahida nexity mme pin qui se sont
réunis hier soir en sommet virtuel d'un
échange pour apaiser les tensions et
établir les règles de la concurrence
entre les états unis et la chine les
deux dirigeants ont convenu de poser des
garde-fous pour éviter un conflit ouvert
à des discussions qualifiée de franche
et directe mais elle ne devrait pas
déboucher sur des résultats concrets
pour plus de précision on va tout de
suite retrouvé tomas bonnet notre
correspondant à washington
[Musique]
bonjour thomas vous êtes à washington
c'est dans ce contexte de tension
croissante entre les deux pays que s'est
déroulée donc cet échange entre les
présidents chinois et le président
américain
oui et paradoxalement malgré ce contexte
de tension c'est dans une tonalité très
amicale que s'est ouvert cet échange
entre joe biden et le président jean
ping alors seuls les quinze premières
minutes de cet entretien ont été
ouvertes à la presse et au cours de ces
échanges que l'on a pu donc voir sur les
images captées par les caméras qui
étaient présentes on a vu où on a pu
voir à des échanges d'amabilités de
politesse même comme quand lorsque par
exemple at-il jingping a qualifié joe
biden comme son vieil ami en tout cas ce
qu'on peut retenir de cet échange qui a
donc été rendue accessible aux
journalistes c'est la volonté en
apparence des deux puissances de
s'accorder à maintenir un dialogue
direct et franc entre les deux
diplomaties je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de cet échange
il me semble que nous devons établir des
garde-fous de bon sens être clair et
honnête lorsque nous ne sommes pas
d'accord et travailler ensemble lorsque
nos intérêts ce recours notamment sur
les questions mondiales vital comme le
changement climatique
la chine et les etats-unis doivent se
respecter mutuellement coexister en paix
poursuivre une coopération gagnant
gagnant je suis prêt à travailler avec
vous pour établir un consensus prendre
des mesures actives et faire évoluer les
relations entre la chine et les états
unis dans une direction positive
cela permettrait de faire avancer les
intérêts de nos deux peuples et de
répondre aux attentes de la communauté
internationale
voilà donc pour la partie protocolaire
la partie ouverte à la presse puisque
ensuite c'est à l'abri des regards que
se sont déroulées les discussions des
échanges qui ont duré près de quatre
heures entre les deux présidents qui
étaient tous les deux accompagnés de
leur conseiller diplomatique il faut
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets sur la
table entre la chine et les états unis
beaucoup de sujets de tension notamment
est le sujet qui cristallise le plus les
tensions ces derniers mois c'est la
question de taiwan taiwan il en ai vu
tom en question dans le communiqué qui a
été publié il ya quelques instants
seulement par la maison blanche pour ce
qui concerne la position américaine sur
le sujet de taiwan écoutez
en ce qui concerne taïwan le président
biden a souligné que les états unis
restent attachés à la politique d'une
seule chine l'idée par la loi sur les
relations avec taiwan les trois
communiqués conjoints et les six
assurances et que les états unis
s'opposent fermement aux efforts
unilatéraux visant à modifier le statut
quo ou à compromettre la paix et la
stabilité dans le détroit de taiwan
et puis toujours sur le sujet de taiwan
du côté des médias chinois on indique
que le président anti jingping a prévenu
les états unis de ne pas jouer avec le
feu et puis dans le communiqué qui a
aussi donc été publiée par la maison
blanche
celle ci indique que joe biden a fait
part de ses préoccupations en ce qui
concerne les droits de l'homme en chine
noter qu'il n'y a pas de communiqué
conjoint qui a été publié à l'issue de
cet échange cela avait déjà plus ou
moins été annoncé par la maison blanche
qui avait tenu à tempérer les attentes
autour de ce sommet virtuel entre thiais
jingping et joe biden en expliquant et
qu'il ne fallait pas s'attendre à des
annonces majeures on peut donc le
vérifier suite aux différentes
informations qui nous parviennent de ces
discussions alors ce qui retient surtout
l'attention aux etats unis c'est la
posture la stratégie adoptée par joe
biden qui compte multiplier et maintenir
les échanges avec son homologue chinois
xi jingping cela il lui est reproché
notamment par des républicains notamment
par donald trump qui lui a fait ce
reproche il ya là quelques jours à peine
en fait les républicains reprochent à
dubaï donne une certaine forme de
faiblesse vis-à-vis de la chine mais on
sait que l'ancien vice président veut
maintenir une diplomatie très direct une
stratégie un peu à l'ancienne dans ce
qui concerne la diplomatie sur la scène
internationale on verra si ce contact
privilégié avec son homologue chinois il
aime beaucoup rappelé qu'il connected
jingping depuis de nombreuses années on
verra si ce contact privilégié portera
ses fruits
en ce qui concerne les relations sino
américaines merci beaucoup trop mal pour
toutes ces précisions thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
matin